I often do look at the pile of stuff at
work and think maybe I should stick that
on my face the Bob bugs project started
was just my Instagram account and I
started using it for an art diary I got
an idea every day i disguised myself in
some way day 363 now for a creative
breakthrough my name is Michael Gump
I am art director and a prop master for
crazy TV shows and I'm also known as Bob
bucks the master of disguise project is
partly to build creative strength or
maybe to like exercise creative demons
you know in a way that's not just at my
job but also for my own evil wishes you
look at the picture maybe seems like it
took a million years I'm usually like I
hate this done I gotta get that so I
just like I get my stuff and I just show
it all up and search so I usually like
you know start with this area and then
work my way out and then it'll be like
people ask does it huh one that stands
out in my mind was like kind of like
what am i doing I I was putting clothes
pins on my face
and so I started sticking them on there
and then and then I kind of panicked
over that I took them all off I was like
okay and then I was like okay this is
gonna be fine and then and then I put
them all back on like you get used to
discomfort pretty fast but I'm concerned
that it's definitely not that good for
my skin do you have a favorite I do have
a special place in my heart for the one
that's like a green mr. t because I just
think it's funny like mister green tea I
call it it's been a kind of exhausting
process in some ways I usually only get
like maybe three hours of sleep a night
the discovery of the project and part of
the point of the project is that you
don't always know what's good so on the
days that I really feel tired I don't
really want to do it I don't really have
a very good idea
sometimes those projects come out better
than the ones that I'm really excited
about what's next we wrapped wait and
see
[Music]
[Music]
35% of Americans between 18 and 45 you
have at least one tattoo on their body
upon your death those tattoos are gone
they're only permanent as long as you're
alive and then they're gone we've
changed that world so all of these
tattoos used to be on someone's body yes
every one of them
[Music]
Charles Hamm has a lot of tattoos I am
the executive director and chairman of
the board of National Association for
the preservation of skin art we call it
naphtha you know I got all these
beautiful tattoos and I'm gonna cremate
it when I die and everything goes up in
smoke so all the meaning all the things
that people know about me that are close
to me are gone as well so Charles which
tattoo do I get I can't say but he
boasted my upper bodies claimed so why
would anyone want their tattoos cut off
and hung on a wall for posterity
this is Shelley Craney
she's one of NASA's first members I was
really nervous when I first got my
tattoo done to show my mom the first
thing that she said when she saw it was
that like it's so beautiful I wish that
I could like hang that on my wall this
is on my body forever now it can be part
of someone else's story forever thanks
to NASA here's how it all works within
hours of a person's death naps I will
mail a preservation kit to their family
the mortician
will then cut off the tattooed skin and
applied abscess embalming solution the
tattoo is then mailed to Knapp's US
headquarters inside this office complex
just outside of Cleveland Ohio this is
where they finished processing the
tattoo it's no longer skin now it has
the look of leather but it feels like
parchment paper finally Knapp's a-- says
the framed tattoo to the beneficiary
everybody thought it was crazy at first
in my family but they quickly came to
realize this is a beautiful thing and
they've claimed their tattoos
I have a gorilla on my chest and
gorillas are known for protecting all
their females in their in their group
and my wife's name resides under that
that's my that's that's my way of saying
that I'm protecting my wife this
gorillas overlooking her so upon my
passing that put in a frame sitting
above a fireplace will remind her of me
every time that she looks at it and
that's really what this is about
I was never raised to be a racist was
never a part of my life until I was in
prison I was born out of pure necessity
do you have to change who you are
[Music]
when you come to jail you come to prison
you got your white gangs you got your
black gangs if you step outside of that
you're not only gonna have one enemy
you're gonna have to the tattoo for me
was definitely like a shield the day I
got released I was determined not just
give up and say that's who I am and I
realized that I can change this my name
is Dave cutlip and we run Redemption ink
I have been tattooing for over 20 years
we help people get a second chance by
removing racist and gang tattoos for
free we started about six months ago
I've done 16 cover-ups now the demand
for this to be honest with you it's
overwhelming i'ma try and do it at least
once a week either here at conventions
you know until I just can't tattoo
anymore
people are just going full-bore trying
to get help and most of them might have
to say that they're already moved on
they just still have the tattoos that
are holding them back like I'm glad that
I have a talent that I can help somebody
those people deserve the pat on the back
not me they did what they needed to do
to change their lives the end of the day
I do my daughter picking up on that
message and I didn't want my daughter
thinking like that type of thinking is
right or asking me where I got it or why
I got it she doesn't have to see any of
that and I'm just like grateful for that
every day that she never had to see me
as that person
you
the tools belong to the cook Islanders
Tarte au was current in the islands it's
just that colonialism had wiped it out
there's not anyone else
[Music]
the revival here started out from tattoo
machine the machine is not connected to
the old ways so I think that gap is vast
for an outsider to stand up in their app
and hold the tools up it can be
challenging I have a lung condition from
something that I'm born with it's not
something that I contracted and it's
also something that you can't catch
cystic fibrosis is the name for me it's
personally been a helping hand you know
it's been something that's I felt like
made me engage in life
[Music]
what makes waffle a good student he
carries the tools well he takes
responsibility very serious I think the
importance of teaching you know and
having the apprentice you know what we
do is something that's been done for a
really long time the actor now are
sharing that with mobile confirms them
the responsibility of the tools is an
important one because the tools the
designs they don't belong to me and it's
something that's been passed down so
it's my responsibility to ensure they're
in safe hands
[Music]
it's like being a caretaker being a
caretaker of everything it's like using
it with love and passion and respect
[Music]
you